um the big thing for me was talking to
women like growing up I feel like that
was scary I can't remember asking this
one girl for my for a number and I'd
even prep and then I was like oh crap
she was gonna give it to me but my dumb
ass didn't have a pen or anything so
then her I ran up and I asked everybody
for a pen and I gave it to her and her
friend was standing there like yo are
you nervous
and then like I'm like whoa and then I
got this pen and I gave it to her and
then she's like where's the paper and
I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah and then and she's
like write it on your [ __ ] hand and I
was like oh okay and I [ __ ] did it
and I was like make it big so it doesn't
wipe off and then she wrote her number
and in my hand was shaking she's like oh
my god you're shaking
that's so cute and I was so [ __ ]
embarrassed man when I got her number
and we talked like every single day and
I'm so glad that I went for it because I
would see her like walking around high
school like all the [ __ ] time and I'm
like man I want her so bad you never
ended up getting together but I think
that that that really got me to feel
like man I don't want to be nervous
around women cuz like it makes me feel
like so stupid and it's a bad first
impression yeah so what I did was I just
started talking to women I was attracted
to but places where they had to talk to
me I'm at the mall like if they're
working at Foot Locker or whatever or
anywhere I'm just like she's a cute girl
like I would I wouldn't do the whole
pick-up guy thing because that was just
a little too weird for me but you want
to show them your youtube I wouldn't be
like hey man this is who I am have you
heard of just kidding films you should
do some research on me first because I'm
gonna let you know how awesome I am well
we try well in high school we would go
to the mall and do that whole thing and
you try to talk to girls and stuff that
are your age or whatever right but then
like over the years I just want I just I
just wanted to get better at
conversation and just like having small
talk and not being so nervous because
this person was attractive yeah so I
talked to men women like everyone and
then when it came down to a hot girl I
was just like oh [ __ ] but then I would
just talk to them and I'm like well you
know what I'm not trying to
with them I'm not trying to like be with
them I'm just trying to like talk about
nothing and I realized that the only
reason why I was so nervous is because
half half of the time I'm just thinking
about [ __ ] them and if I'm gonna get
that so like your minds not in the right
place cuz you're already like if you
don't get it then it's already a loss in
your head so you're nervous of the loss
yeah but if you think about it as just
like oh I just want to exchange a
sentence with this person yeah and then
cool like oh I made a smile cool
whatever we just and then after after
that it just doesn't even matter how hot
they are you just talk to them like
whatever you know what the best I think
the the best thing that I ever did that
actually kind of helps me out as an
adult now especially when it comes to
talking to women not that it matters
anymore Mariel but is that I learned to
talk to women
like you don't want anything from them
yeah girls are very intuitive people
like they know you're [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] thirsty as [ __ ] yeah like they
think they can [ __ ] sense that and
when your motivation for to talk to a
girl is simply because you just want to
[ __ ] them girls can sense that [ __ ]
right and if something does develop like
I think for me too like it's now has
developed it to the point now where I
can literally come up to a girl that
I've had a conversation with I could
look them straight in the [ __ ] eye
and say you're very beautiful yeah but
that's just it there's no see you later
yeah there's no like there's no like hey
you are you [ __ ] fine like there's
nothing that is what I just I just have
to let you know that your swag was so
it's like that situation right it's
disgusting like I can literally look
it's a look at a girl if it works for
you just let me know that but uh if
situations like I could take look at a
girl and say wow you're very you're very
beautiful and just leave it at that it's
just because that's how I feel that's
what I see and that's what it is I could
do the same for a deuce I mean you are a
handsome looking [ __ ] guy yeah but
there's no weirdness to you you don't
have that like I'm trying to [ __ ]
everything energy yeah right or like
I'm so desperate I need to stick my
[ __ ] dick in somebody because I'm a
virgin energy like that's just weird
[ __ ] energy and I think I wish I knew
this younger too because I think I'd be
like way better with relationships and
women and stuff like that if I
understood energy and myself yeah and a
lot of people just don't get that yeah
they're especially guys guys are too
[ __ ] logical everything's like
robotic right like what might help is
like sports yeah
or doing music or doing art but focusing
on how you feel because if you're
nervous and anxious
she'll sense that yeah not just women
but like in a group like if you want
more confidence at the workplace if
you're hanging out with your friends you
want to be heard like you gotta have you
gotta check your energy and what you're
projecting out there yeah yeah yeah and
that's my guess is easier said and said
than done for most people but you know
you're not gonna know unless you [ __ ]
try man repetition repetition and we
made plenty of mistakes I was watching
this one podcast with you know Dan
Bilzerian yep he was on he was he was
being interviewed and they're like how
do you do it like how do you talk to all
these girls how do you whatever and he
goes oh I stopped chasing women so his
whole thing was like he was once that
person that was super nervous around
girls right so he started just he said
every time I saw a superhot girl I would
just start a conversation and he's like
and he's like a thousand times out of a
thousand he's like I'm pretty much
getting rejected but he's like at the
grocery store at whatever at the club
we're just talking and talking and
talking anyway and after a while like I
feel comfortable talking to everyone
right yeah and then so he doesn't have
the thirst energy and he says that when
he started just partying and having fun
and just attracting fun he attracted
people that want to have fun and then he
would take all these cool photos with
all these hot models and that's when it
really started to go high for him
because all these other he's like
there's something crazy with hot women
like if how women see other hot women
with you they all want a peek
hmm so it makes you hotter yeah and he
says I don't even [ __ ] do anything
they just all want to be in my photos
and all the parties III I remember
somebody telling me that Dan Bilzerian
they go oh how much do you pay these
girls he says like I don't [ __ ] pay
them yeah are you crazy he goes I only
want to be around women if they truly
want to be around me yeah he goes I'm
not gonna pay anybody any money to do
this then a lot of them are his
girlfriends yeah so the way he's he said
it is like he's like well in our
relationships it's all about honesty and
he's like we'll probably be with each
other for like three months out of time
but he's like it's okay if they have
boyfriends or whatever and he's like
maybe in the LA fake world that they're
in that's very refreshing because he'll
tell them like I slept with this many
people this week complete honesty a
thousand percent so then when the girls
hear that they're like what cuz
everyone's got like side lovers and fake
lovers and everyone's cheating and in
that world you know and then he says
that's how he he's dating them and
that's the last it's interesting it's
true though because I think this is like
a Hollywood thing that maybe a lot of
people don't really believe yeah and I
could say this and you probably won't
believe it until you're a part of this
this realm but it's almost more common
that people cheat them they don't and oh
yeah having a stable relationship is
like weird yeah yes it's it's weird like
I'll have a conversation with a couple
of dudes and they're just like yo so
like so who are you [ __ ] around with
when you're touring and I'm like nobody
like what you mean like no matter what
you mean nobody it's like bro like the
[ __ ] but you get like [ __ ] Thrones you
want you just you know take one down as
they would say and I'm like oh so this
is the common thing I'm the I'm the
outsider yeah I was like oh okay I
didn't know that and that's not me
putting judgment on them because if
that's a mutual agreement that they have
with their partners and that's that's
what it is but for me I guess or for all
of us it's like oh that's not the norm
yeah that's not the norm like it almost
makes me feel like I'm the one being
done like I'm not taking this
opportunity or some [ __ ] it's like this
just feels weird
it feels very weird it's either I'm
single and I'm just having fun and I'm
[ __ ] around or I'm with someone and
like my dick belongs to one
hahaha I got one giant dude too much to
think about anyways like if you know
like I don't know man IRA it's like if
I'm in relationship mode like my mind is
just more serious yeah it feels like
everyone's a waste of time I kind of
want to would love to bring somebody on
this podcast that is somebody who has a
stable person and then they have a bunch
of side chicks right like if they have
an open relationship with that person
like what that's like yeah and what it
feels like because for me how I see it
as is a big headache cuz it's hard to
deal with one person's emotion having to
deal with multiple people's emotions is
[ __ ] difficult well I think if
everyone understands the arrangement it
like let's say the side people yeah they
know they're just well where's that [ __ ]
then I think that's fine because that's
kind of cool right if you think about it
like you have your you have your partner
and your partner's fine with you it's
almost like watching porn because it's
just a sexual thing like or just a
person that's also a friend that you
might [ __ ] from time to time but you're
not necessarily romantically close with
them
Tugg ice but I think there's always
feelings that get caught so that's
what's weird to me I saw this episode of